what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu and of course
spider-man and everything going on over
at sony's spider-man universe and as we
all know a lot tends to happen over in
that universe both good and bad and
recently the sony universe did some
rescheduling of some of their current
release dates for movies like craven the
hunter and while they did this they
rescheduled what they have listed as an
untitled sony
marvel universe movie now obviously
anytime we see something labeled this
this piques our curiosity we want to
know what the heck is going on and of
course since it says marvel sony a
spider-man fans want to assume that it
is a spider-man movie well this date
both does and doesn't make sense for it
to be the official spider-man 4 release
date and i'll explain in this video and
of course if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on all of
the latest marvel and spider-man news so
like i said sony went around and shifted
some of their release dates for some
upcoming spider-man universe movies
craven the hunter which was originally
planned for january of
2023 will now open in october
specifically october 6th of 2023 now
some fans may remember that october 6th
is actually when madame webb was
supposed to be coming out so now that
craven the hunter is in that slot
obviously madame webb is not so madame
webb has been pushed back now officially
to february 16th of 2024
now this moves the untitled sony slash
marvel universe movie from june to july
12th of 2024 so not a really big move
here but the title makes us wonder what
this movie is going to be it's hard to
imagine it being anything other than
spider-man because of what they label it
a sony
marvel universe film that is extremely
specific and they specifically mention
the marvel universe that is very
different than the sony universe so this
has to be a movie that is taking place
in the mcu unless they very loosely and
poorly titled this but like i said this
is a very specific title so i doubt it
but let's talk about what movie this
could possibly be there can really only
be one maybe two if sony decides to dip
another movie into the mcu which is
possible but let's talk about these two
the first one of course is spider-man 4.
now i've stated this in several other
videos but still a lot of people have
come to me and asked me about spider-man
4 stating that they're worried because
sony and marvel haven't announced a
spider-man 4 yet and that tom holland
says that he has been offered an
official contract yet so it's not
official and yes i hear you and i
understand but you have to think back to
about a week after spider-man no way
home took place kevin feige the
president of marvel studios of course
and amy pascal executive producer over
at sony very clearly stated that they
are working on the next spider-man film
and kevin feige actually said the only
reason that they told us that is so the
fans didn't have to worry about any type
of deal falling through between sony and
marvel if you've been a big fan of the
mcu for over about three years now you
know exactly what i'm talking about
after spider-man far from home came out
there were a lot of reports stating that
sony was going to be taking spider-man
out of the mcu because sony and disney
slash marvel could not agree on a deal
for spider-man remember sony owns the
rights on screen to spider-man but
marvel wanted more money because they
put him in the mcu and made him very
very successful and for a while it did
look like spider-man was going to be
taken out of the mcu however luckily for
us they worked everything out so kevin
feige and amy pascal came out right away
and said they're working on the next
film and they're telling us so we don't
have to worry about that happening again
so spider-man 4 is confirmed the only
question is is this the official release
date for it and it does make sense that
it would be we should assume that tom
holland's spider-man is going to be in
avengers secret wars we should assume
that tom holland's spider-man is indeed
going to be a big part of the avengers
moving forward once they kind of form
again because right now there isn't
really an official avengers team in the
mcu but that means that marvel studios
and sony are going to need one more
spider-man film in the mcu before this
happens especially since both sony and
marvel did announce that another film
was coming it's obviously not going to
come after secret wars because too much
is going to happen and it could even
kind of reset the mcu so that movie has
to come before secret wars so this
release date is probably it and i'll
explain why but first big thank you to
mint mobile for sponsoring this video
most people know about mint mobile
because of ryan reynolds but most people
don't know about mint mobile's amazing
quality now i live in the mountains and
service isn't too good however mint
mobile sent me a free plan and i get
better service with their plan than i do
with my other provider but what's crazy
is their plan is so much cheaper mint
mobile offers wireless for just 15 bucks
a month they give you the best rate
whether you're buying for one or a
family and at mint mobile families start
at only two lines all plans come with
unlimited talk and text plus high speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5g network plus mint mobile's modern
family plan lets you mix and match data
plans so everyone gets the amount of
data that's right for them and you can
use your own phone and keep your same
number and contacts so to get your new
wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
including the modern family plan go to
mintmobile.com cosmic that's mint
mobile.com cosmic cut your wireless
build down to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com
cosmic one of the reasons that i think
that this could be the slot for
spider-man 4 is because marvel studios
when they announce their phases phase 5
phase six phase four in the past they
never announce spider-man movies if you
take a look at when kevin feige
officially announced phase three or
phase four you won't find any spider-man
movies on there anywhere the same goes
for phase five and phase six yes they
have revealed all of phase five and they
have revealed some of phase six but
notice spider-man was not on phase five
anywhere however he wouldn't be it would
be the same as phase three and phase
four they wouldn't show spider-man but
he would be in there somewhere and like
i said since this movie has to come out
before secret wars this release date is
probably for spider-man 4 putting it
inside of phase 5 before phase 6 where
everything starts to go down the
fantastic four the king dynasty and
secret wars and if we stop and consider
some of the rumors that have been going
around recently this release date makes
even more sense if we consider the fact
that andrew garfield and toby mcguire
are probably returning for secret wars
as well there is just too much that
needs to happen in a spider-man 4 movie
for a spider-man 4 movie to take place
right before everything happens in phase
six at the end of spider-man no way home
the memory of peter parker was erased
from everybody mj ned doctor strange
happy and maybe wang she hulk made it
kind of sound like he kind of knew who
spider-man was and maybe it's just
spider-man and not peter parker we'll
have to wait and see on that but they
have to address this in spider-man 4 and
they have to clear it because obviously
we're going to have something happen
where everybody remembers who peter is
again maybe not everybody but those
people i just mentioned that are really
close to him and of course the avengers
and at the end i really hope they
address the multiverse and also of
course the other two spider-man andrew
and toby and if they are going to be
talking about the spell that erased
everybody's memory it would make sense
that they would have to talk about the
whole multiverse incident and then that
could lead into the whole loki
multiverse incident and how everything
is kind of messed up now and kang is
coming so that would be a perfect setup
leading into phase six leading into the
king dynasty and then of course into
secret wars where toby and andrew could
return so although i can't confirm it
because it's not been confirmed yet it
does seem likely that this slot could be
for spider-man 4. now in the off chance
that sony simply labeled this very
poorly stating that it was a sony marvel
universe film the only other film that i
think that it could possibly be is venom
3. this would kind of make sense because
we know that spider-man is going to be
in venom 3 tom hardy has teased that
multiple times already plus we have the
post-credits scene for venom let there
be carnage which was just a giant giant
tease and then of course the post-credit
scene for spider-man no way home showed
venom in the mcu and although it does
seem like tom hardy's venom is going to
go up against a different spider-man
that is not tom holland and vice versa
as well tom hardy's venom very well
could go up against tom holland's
spider-man it seemed like they kind of
made these two post-credit scenes
confusing on purpose and heck there is
even the possibility that we still could
see tom hardy play venom except we could
see his variant in the mcu play venom
that would be kind of weird but that is
a way around it but of course do not
rule out andrew garfield spider-man
returning to go up against tom hardy's
venom in the sony universe remember the
line from spider-man knowing home where
he said i want to fight an alien now
technically that would not be a marvel
universe movie however again like i
stated if they simply chose poor wording
for this title that's what the movie
could be so i'm guessing that this
release date is most likely for
spider-man 4 but it also could be for
venom 3. it is really close to the
thunderbolts release date but hey if you
got to get a spider-man movie in there
you got to get one in there so let me
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video please and of course subscribe
to stay up to date on the latest mcu and
spider-man news for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof